since James commis testimony this  morning I've been getting a ton of angry  phone calls you see I knew that millions  of people we're gonna be watching our  sister channel CNN this morning and I  saw an opportunity and I guess I went  too far I think you'll see what I'm  talking about check it out  did you ever have access to the actual  part about this or did you have to rely  on a third party I understood that I  served at the pleasure of the president  even though I was we are the leaders of  the FBI so it's been reported to us and  then I heard it and now I've shared it  with the leaders of the FBI our  conversation was should we share this  with  you  you